♪ ♪
>> Laura: EARLIER TODAY THE
D.A. OF GEORGIA GEORGE FORMER
POLICE OFFICER GARRETT ROLE FOR
WITH FELONY MURDER INTENT OF
THEIR CHARGES ON THE DEATH OF
RAYSHARD BROOKS.
AND ALSO CHARGED A SECOND POLICE
OFFICER WHO WAS AT THE SCENE
WITH AGGRAVATED ASSAULT AND TWO
COUNTS OF VIOLATION OF OATH BY
AN OFFICER.
AND ALSO MY SHOT AND KILLED
BROOKS A BLACK MAN.
AS PART OF THE SHOOTING OCCURRED
AFTER HE FAILED A SOBRIETY TEST
AFTER HANDCUFFED MO BROOKS
OVERPOWERED THE TWO POLICE
OFFICERS, STOLE A TASER, RUN AWA
AND POINTED BACK AT HIM WITH IT
DESPITE BROOKS IS ACTION CAUGHT
ON A BODY CAM, THIS IS HOW THE
DAs COUNTED THE BEHAVIOR.
>> MR. BROOKS ON THE NIGHT OF
THE INCIDENT WAS CALM.
HE WAS CORDIAL, AND REALLY
DISPLAYED A COOPERATIVE NATURE.
WE CONCLUDED AND CONSIDERED IT
AS ONE REPORT IN CONSIDERATION
THAT MR. BROOKS NEVER PRESENTED
HIMSELF AS A THREAT.
>> Laura: JOINING ME NOW AND
IN THE EXCLUSIVE IS LANCE
LARUSSO FORMER OFFICER GARRETT
ROLFE’S ATTORNEY.
LANCE WERE YOU WITH SURPRISE TO
HEAR THAT HE NEVER PRESENTED
HIMSELF AS A THREAT BUT A
CORDIAL CONVERSATION.
>> IT WAS SHOCKING TO HEAR THAT
BECAUSE IT’S NOT TRUE.
>> Laura: THE ALTERCATION WAS
OBVIOUS TO ANYONE WHO SAW THE
VIDEO.
IT WENT ON FOR 20 MINUTES, THE
CONVERSATION, DO YOU WANT TO
COME WITH US?
THAT WENT ON FOR SOME TIME.
BUT THEN IT IS CLEAR HE
STRUGGLES AGAINST BOTH OFFICERS
AND OVERPOWER THEM.
SO WHY DO YOU THINK THE D.A. IS
EMPHASIZING ONLY THE NICE
CONVERSATION PART, WHICH THE
OFFICER DEMONSTRATED
PROFESSIONALISM, I THOUGHT.
>> I HAVE NO IDEA WHY HE’S DOING
THAT.
THERE’S A LOT OF THINGS I HAVE
NO IDEA.
HE IS SAYING ONE OF THE OFFICERS
IS COOPERATING WITH THE D.A.’S
OFFICE.
THAT LAWYER FOR THAT OFFICER
SAID THAT’S NOT TRUE.
WHAT THEY SHOULD BE FOCUSED ON
IS WHY IT CHANGED FROM A CORDIAL
CONVERSATION TO A VIOLENT
ASSAULT INTO LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS AT THE MOMENT THAT
MR. BROOKS KNEW HE WAS GOING TO
JAIL.
>> Laura: HE WENT AFTER THE
CLIENT WITH A TASER.
>> [INAUDIBLE]
>> I DON’T KNOW IF YOU CAN SEE
IT CLEARLY...
P DON’T ASK ME WHEN HE ADMITS
THERE WAS A TASER SHOT AT YOUR
CLIENT COME ALTHOUGH IT WENT AT
HIS HEAD, HE SAID.
I WANT TO GET TO THAT IN A
MOMENT.
I WANT TO DESCRIBE THE USE OF A
TASER TWO WEEKS AGO.
>> HAS MANY OF YOU UNDER GEORGIA
LAW, A TASER IS A DEADLY WEAPON
UNDER GEORGIA LAW.
>> Laura: OKAY, LANCE, EDUCATE
ME.
IT IS A TASER NO LONGER A DEADLY
WEAPON IF IT MISSES THE HEAD OF
A POLICE OFFICER?
>> IT WENT OVER HIS HEAD TO
COMMIT IT IS BECAUSE IT WENT
INTO HIS FACE.
THAT IS THE EXACT PROBLEM WITH A
PERSON WHO IS NOT TRAINED AND
WHY IT BECOMES A DEADLY
INCAPACITATED WEAPON ESPECIALLY
IN THE HANDS OF SOMEBODY ALREADY
COMMITTED A ROBBERY AND FORCIBLY
DISARMED WHEN UNIFORM
LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICER.
WHEN A LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICER
USES A TASER IN THE COURSE OF A
LAWFUL ARREST COMMIT HIS
NONLETHAL FORCE BECAUSE THE
OFFICERS TRAINED HOW TO SHOOT
IT, WHERE TO SHOOT IT AND ONE OF
THE THINGS THEY SAY IS
NONLETHAL, S LETHAL OR TASER,
TASER, TASER.
THAT IS DONE FOR TWO REASONS SO
THAT OFFICERS AROUND THEM KNOW
THEY ARE NOT SHOOTING A WEAPON
AND THAT THE SUSPECT IS NOT
SHINING BACK AT THEM BECAUSE A
TASER WHEN IT GOES OFF SOUNDS
LIKE A FIREARM.
>> Laura: WELL, HERE IS HOW
THE LOGGER FOR THE BROOKS FAMILY
DESCRIBED THE DEADLY ENCOUNTER
WITH YOUR CLIENT.
WATCH.
>> WHAT WE ARE LOOKING AT IS
WHAT IS IT REASONABLE,
PROPORTIONATE AND NECESSARY?
YOU CAN SEE THE OFFICER REACHED
FOR THE GUN BEFORE MR. BROOKS
TURNS AROUND WITH THE TASER.
I MEAN THAT IS CLEARLY VISIBLE
IN THE VIDEO.
HE WAS ALREADY GOING IN THAT
DIRECTION, GOING TO THE LETHAL
FORCE DIRECTION BEFORE THAT
TASER WAS PLANTED IN HIS
DIRECTION.
>> Laura: LANCE, DOESN’T
MATTER THAT YOU HAD HIS HAND ON
HIS GUN?
>> AT THAT POINT THE OFFICER
SHOULD BE WONDERING WHAT’S GOING
ON BEHIND THEM.
IT IS FOR SOMEBODY WITH ANOTHER
TYPE OF WEAPON THAT WE DIDN’T
SEE?
IS HE TRYING TO CARJACK
SOMETHING?
EVERYBODY IN THE AREA IS DANGER.
THE PROBLEM IS WHEN WE SAW THIS
IN THE VIDEO THE D.A. BROKE THIS
DOWN AND SAID LOOK HERE, WE
ENHANCE THE VIDEO 12 FEET APART.
LOOK HERE THE OFFICER WAS
LEANING AGAINST THE CAR.
HE’S LEANING AGAINST THE CAR
BECAUSE HE THINKS HE’S GOING TO
GET KILLED AND THE OFFICER’S
MIND, BRAIN AND ABILITY TO SEE
DOES NOT HAVE THE ABILITY TO
ENHANCE VIDEO.
HE IS SAYING ALL OF THIS
HAPPENING QUICKLY.
HE’S REACTING TO WHAT’S
HAPPENING QUICKLY AND I’M TIRED
OF GETTING PEOPLE SAY MR. BROOKS
WAS RUNNING AWAY.
MR. BROOKS WAS NOT RUNNING AWAY.
MR. BROOKS TURNED AND OFFERED
EXTREME VIOLENCE TOWARDS A
UNIFORMED LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICER.
IF HE WAS ABLE TO DEPLOY A
TASER PERMIT WOULD INCAPACITATE
OFFICER ROLFE THROUGH HIS BODY
ARMOR AND AT THAT POINT IF YOU
DECIDED TO DISARM ANOTHER
OFFICER, HE WOULD BE IN
POSSESSION OF ANOTHER FIREARM.
>> Laura: THE D.A. GAVE
ANOTHER VIEW SAYING THAT
IMMEDIATELY FOR 2 MINUTES AND 12
SECONDS AFTER THE SHOOTING, HE
SAID THIS HAPPENED.
>> THERE WAS NO MEDICAL
ATTENTION APPLIED TO MR. BROOKS.
WHEN WE EXAMINED THE VIDEOTAPE
AND IN OUR DISCUSSION WITH
WITNESSES, WHAT WE DISCOVERED IS
DURING THE 10 MINUTES AND 12
SECONDS THAT OFFICER ROLFE
ACTUALLY KICKED MR. BROOKS WHILE
HE LAID ON THE GROUND.
>> Laura: WHO WANT TO PLAY
THIS MOMENT THAT WAS ALSO CAUGHT
ON BODY CAM AND GET YOUR
RESPONSE.
>> MR. BROOKS --
MR. BROOKS, KEEP BREATHING FOR
ME.
>> Laura: WENT LANCE, WE JUST
SAW THAT THERE WAS CPR
ADMINISTERED, BUT THE D.A. SAID
TOOK 2 MINUTES AND 12 SECONDS TO
HAPPEN.
TONIGHT, CAN YOU TELL US, IS THE
D.A. STATING THAT CORRECTLY?
>> MY CLIENT NEVER KICKED
MR. BROOKS.
IF THERE WAS A VIDEO OF MY
CLIENT KICKING MR. BROOKS, YOU
WOULD HAVE SEEN IT.
YOU SHOW HIM STILL ONE LEG IS
BENT.
HE COULD BE LEANING DOWN TO GIVE
FIRST AID AND MAY BE TRYING TO
EVALUATE WHETHER HE NEEDED
HANDCUFFS.
THIS OFFICER GAVE HIM CPR,
MONITORED HIS POLLS PRIOR TO
THAT, TALK TO HIM TO KEEP HIM
BREATHING, AND CALLED FOR THE
OTHER EFFORTS ON THE SCENE.
THE OTHER THING THAT THE D.A.
SAID, HE’S NEVER SEEN AN OFFICER
AGREED TO TESTIFY AGAINST A BAD
OFFICER.
MY CLIENT TESTIFIED AGAINST AN
ATLANTA POLICE OFFICER IN THE
GRAND JURY WHEN THAT OFFICER HAD
DONE SOMETHING WRONG.
SO THIS IS AN OFFICER WHO IS
KNOWN TO THE LAW ENFORCEMENT
COMMUNITY.
HE’S KNOWN TO THE D.A.’S OFFICE.
HE WAS ACTUALLY CLEARED OF
ANOTHER USE OF FORCE, AND HE
TESTIFIED ON BEHALF OF THE D.A.
TO PROSECUTE A BAD OFFICER.
>> Laura: IT IS A QUESTION
WHETHER HE WILL GET A FAIR TRIAL
IN THIS CLAIMANT, CERTAINLY, IN
ATLANTA AREA.
I KNOW YOU HAVE A LOT OF DEFENSE
MOTIONS THAT YOU WILL BE FILING,